the movie begins in the year 1983 in a
suburban town in america a father david
rainer is yelling at his eight-year-old
son jake to wake up because he is late
for school when jake doesn't answer
david goes to check on him and comes
across a troubling sight jake has
stopped moving and is secreting fizz
from his mouth without wasting time
david rushes him to the hospital and
discovers that his son is not the only
person who woke up like that the hallway
is full of parents carrying their
children and trying to contact a doctor
in fact according to the news on tv
every single child in the world under
the age of nine has fallen into a
catatonic state reports from the asian
australian and african countries are
flooding in asking for expert advice but
even the smartest scientists have no
idea what is going on chaos ensues as
parents come to the streets to protest
but even they do not know what they are
protesting against days turn into weeks
months and years but the children never
go back to normal every child born after
1983 is born in the same condition
threatening the end of mankind several
laws are formed to protect the rights of
sick children and to stop people from
procreating further this causes economic
and social instability around the globe
which further gives rise to many
problems the only movement the children
make is when they get intense seizures
twice a day at the same time every day
science has no answers to what the
seizures mean just like it has no
answers to the entire plague cut to ten
years later eight-year-old jake has now
turned into an eighteen-year-old boy but
with no life inside of him he is fed and
kept in a healthy condition but david
and other parents of the world have
given up on getting their children back
in david's town the school is closed
after the last batch graduates and the
gym hall is renovated into a hospital
for sick children whose families have no
means to take care of them the head
doctor at the gym is a woman named jean
then we are introduced to gene's
ex-husband tom he went to jail a few
years ago for killing a man in a bar
fight the incident changed his life and
took his job and family away after
serving prison time he has just recently
been let out on parole since tom has no
place to live david allows him to stay
at his house for a few days where tom
also gets to meet jake david has brought
several pieces of medical equipment for
jake's comfort tom comments that they
must have cost a lot but david
rationalizes that nothing will amount to
his son's happiness he seems to believe
that although his son cannot express his
feelings he can still tell what is going
on around him in the evening tom meets
gene who isn't happy to see him they
share a brief conversation before she
asks him to stay away from her tom is
still in love with her but she only sees
him as a murderer the following day tom
goes to the police station to meet his
old mentor and the town's sheriff there
he sees two teenagers who have been
arrested for trespassing ten years ago
they narrowly crossed the age of nine
and were saved from being like the other
kids while most such children are in
bigger cities making a lot of money
these two break into houses and talk to
unconscious children no one knows why
they do it but by the looks of it they
seem to be struggling mentally in the
next scene we see a doctor walking into
the gym for a regular checkup she is met
with horror when she sees that they have
come back to consciousness and are
staring at her the woman cannot believe
her eyes and freezes in shock until one
girl attacks her back in the house tom
wakes up because of the noise and sees
the state of emergency message on tv he
rushes upstairs to check on jake but
finds him missing then he goes to
david's room to discover that his face
has been squashed to death seconds later
jake appears behind him and attacks he
is about to be killed when his childhood
friend and gene's brother sam arrives at
the house he hits the kid with a tire
iron and throws him out the window sam
also reveals that the entire city has
been swarmed by the awoken children
whose only aim is to kill the adults no
one knows what they actually want but
people are dying at a frightening rate
suddenly they remember that jean was
working a night shift which means she is
surrounded by sick children they quickly
make their way outside but are yet again
approached by jake at first he tries to
attack them but stops and falls
unconscious after that tom and sam drive
to the school the first dead body they
find is of a nurse with a deformed face
while trying to climb the stairs they
are attacked by the kids who try to grab
their faces for some reason they are
then saved by the same two teens that
tom saw at the police station earlier
they introduced themselves as kip and
claire it turns out that the killers
think the couple is one of them which is
how they have survived until now tom
asks them to quickly get out of the city
while he and sam continue looking for
gene when in the hallways they are
almost spotted by a horde of the killers
but they managed to hide inside a room
with locked doors they also find a group
of eight survivors waiting for help the
doctors think the police are on their
way to help them unaware that no one in
the town is safe including the police
tom is told that gene went up a vent to
get medicine for an injured survivor he
follows her asking sam to take care of
the others a few minutes later sam hears
someone trying to break the door he
panics and asks the group to go down the
laundry chute they make a rope out of
bed sheets and manage to climb down one
after another sam goes last but halfway
through he hears the others screaming in
pain realizing that they have been
attacked he climbs back up and unties
the bed sheets just then he sees a nurse
trying to climb up the chute but because
of his mistake she falls to her doom
everything goes quiet for a second
before sam sees a guy inside the room
meanwhile tom is crawling through the
vent when he comes across another kid he
is about to be attacked but gene arrives
at the right time to save him they both
come out of the vents deciding to return
to the others however upon reaching the
room they see sam with a bloodied weapon
and no survivors gene is heartbroken
because they were all her colleagues tom
calms her down before the three of them
make their way outside in the hallways
they are joined by kip and claire a
little further they meet the sheriff who
is also looking for survivors all of a
sudden a panicking guard attacks claire
assuming that she is one of the children
before he calms down the actual children
drag him away while the others run to
the door outside the sheriff's wife nora
and the deputy are waiting for the
survivors when they are distracted the
children land an attack somehow the
others arrive at the right time and
manage to free them amidst the chaos
claire is left behind with the children
while the others drive away kip is
worried for her but is hopeful that the
children won't know she is a human the
group stops in the church where gene
takes care of sam's injured leg he yells
in pain for several minutes before she
finally gives him drugs to make him
sleep while everyone stays in a safe
room tom goes around the church to check
if there are more children while
inspecting the chapel he is attacked by
a girl the sheriff runs to see what's up
and is shocked because the girl is his
daughter his wife nora weakens at the
sight of the girl in such a condition
instead of killing her they decide to
tie her hands to the railings somewhere
else kip finds a pastor's journal where
he was writing interesting things about
his dreams a few hours later they see
the pastor outside being swarmed by
children this is a pastor's wet dream
they hold him to the ground while a kid
touches his face and kills him before
dying the pastor says that he is not yet
ready disclosing that he knows something
the others don't why didn't he tell them
then kip then shows the journal to tom
and asks him to read the last entry in
it the pastor has predicted his death
saying that his soul was taken by
children through his face who wants to
bet that he wrote that before the plague
he has also written a line that roughly
translates to the children give what
they receive they are not able to
decipher what it means but tom keeps the
page just in case they need it in the
future meanwhile nora sees her daughter
tearing up and believes that she has
turned into her normal self she quickly
unties her hands only to be attacked and
killed brutally when the sheriff arrives
at the scene his heart drops before his
daughter can do more harm he shoots her
dead and commits the unthinkable in the
morning we see that claire is still
alive she goes to her house and finds
her mother's dead body in the bathtub
with her face crushed in the meantime
the group finds out about an army base
near their town which is their only hope
for survival they pack up all the
necessary stuff and go outside but come
across a broken car it turns out that
the children are getting smarter by the
hour and have learned to disable the
engine in cars they have done the same
to every car in the neighborhood so tom
has to think of another way to escape he
then remembers that david had a car
inside his garage which could still be
working since sam cannot walk he and the
deputy stay at the church while the
other three go out to david's house they
reached the place safely but come across
a girl in the front yard she even has a
gun on her and seems to know how to use
it suddenly claire appears and kills the
girl she also discloses that the
children are learning to do new stuff
and almost all of them have a gun by now
welcome to the south baby back in the
church a horde of children attacks sam
in the deputy a while later the rest of
the group arrives to their dead bodies
jean kneels down near her brother and
breaks into silent sobs she gets up
surprisingly quickly driven by the will
to kill all the children on their drive
to the town's border everyone notices
her stiff demeanor when they are
distracted two guys start firing at the
car the tires go flat causing them to
come to a halt right in the line of fire
tom asks everyone to stay down but gene
doesn't listen she comes out of the car
and ambushes both enemies she continues
fighting even after they are dead while
the others watch in concern now that
they are out of bullets jean wants to
return to the town's police station and
get some from their storage tom argues
otherwise because there is no need for
guns in the army base still jean remains
adamant and makes her way to the police
station on her own kip and claire join
her shortly after leaving tom the odd
one out he walks towards the army base
for some time before sitting down to
read the pastor's note again he
rationalizes that the children are
sucking out people's souls but the way
to stop them isn't clear in the note
meanwhile in the police station they
find two children gathering up the
weapons since they won't suspect claire
she decides to go inside to steal the
guns the other two patiently wait in
another room until they hear a gunshot
kip runs to claire and sees that she has
been shot he kills a man but his intern
shot as well the two sit beside each
other until they ultimately die after
some time passes tom arrives and finds a
frantic gene in the hallways she has
lost all senses and is paranoid that the
children have surrounded her tom gently
brings her back to her senses before
they go outside since they do not have a
vehicle they are soon surrounded by the
children from all sides tom makes gene
kneel down and remember the moment she
was the happiest in her life while she
does so he walks to a kid in the crowd
and tells him that he is ready tom has
finally figured out that the kids give
you back the emotions that you show to
them when you give them fear and anger
they do the same to you seconds later
jean opens her eyes and finds herself
alone in the last scene we see her
reading the pastor's note while enjoying
a beautiful day outside her house then
she sees the children surrounding her
house yet again this time she simply
goes inside leaving the door open as a
sign of trust subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching